got something
looks like we lost him
dr aldeway you have a patient who goes
by the name of dylan forrester he's one
of my most interesting most promising
patients
when was the last time you spoke has you
done something then you mean attempted
murder then yeah well that's progress
is there anything you need to tell me
no you're not the same man you used to
be dee dee's younger brother professor
sean forrester he's dead the funeral is
today
you got a lot of nerve coming here get
me someone in the washington state
police
the fbi he broke his ball short of him
you know the routine
i didn't expect them to be here so soon
[Music]
you can't be the fbi not exactly
search the house first and found out no
one dies until we find out what they
know
trying to do my best here
you know don't be too hard on yourself
oh sure and i'll shoot you both
so now do you understand what happens
when you don't help me jacob
find me a way back in
what aren't you telling me
sean must have told you what's here on
the island
you're being shot at
oh yeah
do whatever it takes to save your energy
did you really kill people uncle
they were really bad people
you